sie ist durchsichtig wie wasser schmeckt
aber angeblich wie cola mit einem hauch
von ingwer und zitrone
manche besucher in diesem café im
berliner stadtteil kreuzberg werden beim
anblick der flasche stutzig
was mich anspricht ist die farbe im
endeffekt weil natürlich mit der farbe
rechnet mit einer cola natürlich
überhaupt nicht erfunden hat das getränk
termin celik für die 39 jährige
berlinerin stand von anfang an fest dass
ihre cola durchsichtig sein soll
sie verzichtete bei ihrer variante
bewusst auf stoffe bedeutet für mich
rein und klar und glam versteht jeder
die idee kam der fünffachen mutter auf
der suche nach einer gesunden cola für
ihre kinder eine mit möglichst wenigen
künstlichen zusatzstoffen nach ihrer
recherche glaubt sie eine marktlücke
entdeckt zu haben
mein erster schritt war ja zu gucken
gibt es so etwas
wenn es so etwas gibt hätte ich das
natürlich sofort wenn meine kinder
bestellt und auch für mich um zu gucken
was für uns ist aber nachdem wir
entdeckt haben es gibt nichts
dergleichen habe ich recherchiert ein
konzept entwickelt mit mir gedacht das
kann ja nicht so schwer seine cola
herzustellen es ist letztendlich auch
nur ein produkt mit zutaten ein jahr an
feilt sie an der rezeptur am ende
entscheidet sie sich für einen geschmack
aus cola ingwer und zitrone
sie verzichtet auf industriellen zucker
und verwendet ausschließlich frucht süße
und ziel ist gesundheitsschädliche
stoffe wie phosphorsäure oder den
farbstoff zucker couleur weg im frühjahr
2013 kommt die erste flasche auf den
markt
verkauft wird die cola alternative etwa
in diesem berliner geschäft bei den
kunden stehen die kreationen kleiner
alternativer getränkehersteller hoch im
kurs
ich denke es liegt daran dass immer mehr
menschen gucken was sie konsumieren was
sie kaufen immer mehr leute gucken was
sie essen und trinken sich darüber
informieren wo das herkommt wie das
hergestellt wird und das liegt im trend
schon seit einigen jahren kommen immer
mehr alternative limonaden getränke auf
den markt sie wollen mit optik und
außergewöhnlichen geschmacksrichtungen
überzeugen
die glam cola kostet ab 1 euro 80 pro
flasche
mittlerweile werden 10.000 liter im
monat hergestellt
doch auch die klare cola tritt gegen
eine große konkurrenz an
wie normale cola ein bisschen
pessimistischer so für mich sehr gut
abgang ja aber im ersten step ist nicht
so schlecht
nermin celik arbeitet bereits an neuen
ideen unter anderem einer koffein freien
variante die dann noch unbedenklicher
für kinder wäre es jetzt in der pipeline
und dann habe ich noch ein drittes
produkt das verrate ich jetzt nicht die
heißt aber dies auch in der pipeline
aber eines ist klar auch ihre neuen
getränke wird wieder durchsichtig